con este vídeo vamos a entender un poco
más qué es la pendiente de una recta y
su intersección con el eje y aquí dice
ajusta la pendiente y la intersección
con el eje y hasta que conecte los dos
puntos cómo afecta la pendiente y la
intersección con el eje y a la recta la
idea principal de estos ejercicios es
que podamos modificar la ecuación para
que la recta que tenemos en esta gráfica
pase por los dos puntos que se nos dan
la ecuación de la recta original que
tenemos aquí es 1 x 1 esta recta es el
resultado de esta ecuación 1 x 1 tiene
una pendiente de 1 y podemos saber eso
porque para cada vez que avanzamos 1 de
la derecha se mueve exactamente 1 hacia
arriba y cruza el eje y en 1 intersecta
el eje y exactamente en el punto 0 1 ok
el objetivo de este ejercicio es cambiar
la pendiente y el punto donde la recta
cruza el eje y para que la recta pase
por estos dos puntos que tenemos aquí
entonces que tenemos que hacer aquí
podemos ver que cuando cambiamos la
pendiente si hago que la pendiente sea
mayor esto produce una recta más
empinada ahora la pendiente es 3 esto
significa que si muevo uno a la derecha
el punto se mueve 3 hacia arriba el
cambio en estrés cada vez que hay un
cambio de 1 en x ésta es la pendiente
pero creo que para conectar estos dos
puntos no necesitamos cambiar la
pendiente en la ecuación original de
esta recta sino que lo que tenemos que
hacer es cambiar el punto donde la recta
interfecta el eje i
la intersección de la recta con el eje y
sigue siendo 1 si hago que disminuye el
punto donde la recta interfecta el eje y
fíjense que la recta se desliza hacia
abajo esto no cambia la inclinación o la
pendiente solo hace que la recta se
mueva hacia abajo a lo largo del eje y
así que parece que solo necesito cambiar
este punto para lograr que la recta
cruce por los dos puntos que se nos dan
al inicio de este ejercicio de hecho
podemos ver que uno de los puntos está
justo en el eje y entonces vamos a
llegar a interceptar la recta en el eje
y en el punto cero menos 8
y llegamos la ecuación de la recta que
pasa por los dos puntos que tenemos aquí
es 1 x menos 8 vamos a comprobar la
respuesta ok es correcta vamos a hacer
otra
una vez más el ejercicio nos presenta la
ecuación de la recta que es igual a 1 x
1 pero aquí me da dos puntos nuevos y
tengo que hacer que la recta pase por
ellos y una vez más vemos que se trata
de una pendiente positiva porque cada
vez que me muevo sobre el eje x hacia la
derecha o sea de forma positiva el eje y
ese va para arriba así que voy a
aumentar la pendiente un poco la aumenta
un poco más se ve bien así que voy a
mover la recta un poco hacia abajo
disminuyendo el punto donde la recta
cruza el eje y ahora tal vez pueda
cruzar por esos dos puntos llegamos esta
es la ecuación de la recta que pasa por
los dos puntos que tenemos aquí
0 - 2 y 26 tenemos entonces la pendiente
igual a 4 que significa que por cada uno
que avancemos a la derecha vamos 4 hacia
arriba lo vemos aquí 1 a la derecha y 12
34 hacia arriba y el punto donde la
recta cruza el eje y es 0 - 2 esta es la
ocasión de nuestra recta comprobamos ok
vamos a hacer otra
una vez más el ejercicio nos da una
recta de 1 x 1 y 2 nuevos puntos para
cruzarlos solo que aquí podemos ver que
la pendiente de la recta que necesitamos
para cruzar estos puntos debe ser
negativa y vamos a modificar la
pendiente de la recta
vemos que nos pone fracciones así que
los saltos serán más pequeños así se ve
bien
parece que llegamos a la pendiente
correcta
ahora vemos que nuestra pendiente es
negativa porque cada vez que avanzamos
uno a la derecha en el eje x el punto se
va para abajo en el eje y ahora tenemos
que modificar la intersección de nuestra
recta con el eje y también nos pone
fracciones así que los saltos serán más
pequeños pero estamos llegando
y parece que tenemos que ajustar nuestra
pendiente ok
llegamos estos ejercicios son divertidos
porque es difícil poner respuestas
incorrectas podemos estar modificando la
ecuación hasta que logremos que la recta
pase por los dos puntos que nos ponen
aquí pero la idea es que podamos
desarrollar la intuición para calcular
la pendiente que podamos saber cuál es
la inclinación de la recta y cuál es el
punto de intersección de la recta con el
eje y si es más abajo o más arriba y la
podemos mover para obtener la ecuación
correcta
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta es